so the big news over the weekend and  it's crazy that the news cycle has  basically moved on is that president  trump tried to work with insiders in the  doj to basically launch  a coup inside the department of justice  president trump worked with the acting  head of the civil division jeffrey clark  to oust the acting attorney general  jeffrey rosen  and basically try and shoehorn all of  his crazy conspiracy theories  through the doj on top of that it  appears that trump is trying to  strong-arm the doj into filing suits  with the supreme court to try and  overturn the election  and the only reason it appears it didn't  work is that members of the doj  threatened to resign on mass  to prevent this from happening and they  thought that the fallout from the mass  resignations would be worse than the  actual actions itself just when you  thought it couldn't get any worse  it gets worse but stay tuned and as  always i will see you  in court